I’d like to share with you guys a story.
This story is about a girl, teenage girl,
like most of us,
and she wanted to be a nurse
because she felt very pleased
to take care and help people.
Well, one day,
she was going to travel by plane,
and she had the opportunity
to fall in love with that huge machine
that makes people fly around the world.
She was quite confused because
how could she manage those passions
she had of taking care of people
and flying at the same time?
How could she do this?
When she entered the airplane,
she saw a very good-looking
woman wearing uniform
helping people to find their seats
with a beautiful smile in her face,
and she decided to be like her someday.
She wanted to be a flight attendant,
to have these opportunities
to fly everyday,
to feel this freedom,
and to be with different people
of different places
and far places, too every day.
Okay, that was her dream.
Well, a dream for us
can mean lots of things.
It can be something that happens inside
our head while we are sleeping,
It can be also a compliment.
You can go to the person
you have a crush on
and say to him or her that,
"oh my god, you're a dream."
But it also can be an ambition,
and that's what
we are talking about today.
An ambition is the strong desire
to reach something,
and I believe that there are a range
of factors that can determine
whether or not we will reach our dreams.
Some of them are
the self-esteem we receive,
the will to succeed we have,
the support we receive,
and the reality,
our realistic vision, actually.
And to make this way of thinking
easier for us,
I decided to turn all these factors
into a math equation,
although I'm not as good
at math as I wish.
The equation was like this:
Y times Z times W times R equals X,
it's very simple,
where Y is your self-esteem,
Z is the support you receive,
W is your will to succeed,
R is your realistic vision
and X is your ambition, your dream.
Interpreting this equation,
we can see that every factor is essential.
There are two observations
that I'd like to tell you guys.
The first one is
if you pay attention here,
you can see that if there is only
one negative unknown in this equation,
it can mess up everything in your life.
For example, if you have self-esteem,
you receive the support,
you have will to succeed,
you have also an awesome realistic vision,
but if you don't have
an ambition in your life,
you have no focus.
It’s like you’re running as fast
as you can with everything
but you don’t know where you’re going.
Another observation,
if you have the support,
also the will to succeed,
you have an awesome realistic vision,
and you also have an ambition,
but you don't have self-esteem,
you will hardly reach your dreams
because you won't feel able enough for it
and if you reach it,
although it's a victory,
you won't feel completely satisfied
with yourself
because you'll feel
there's a part of you missing.
Another point that
I'd like to share with you
is that the only external element
that is here in this equation
is the support we receive.
This support we receive
is directly related
to our society and what it enforces.
So when we are called to do something,
something that we never saw someone
like us, apparently like us, doing,
you won't feel able enough to do it.
Can you understand that?
So I'd like to ask you guys a question.
How much support do you get from
this current society?
Getting back to our story,
our protagonist, she didn't receive
a lot of support from society.
She decided to search more about
this career that she wanted to have,
and she realized some huge variations
between her
and the idea of flight attendant
according to this current society.
This current society, in her thoughts,
couldn't agree with the idea of
a black-skinned woman with curly braided hair
to be a flight attendant.
Of course, she was sad about it.
She couldn't do, be, or live
the way she wanted to
because of her apperance.
She decided to quit
about this dream she had.
One day at her school,
she was going to an event,
a vocational guidance,
and the special guest
in this vocational guidance
was a British guy.
While the event was going on,
he was paying attention to her,
and that was kind of weird to her.
And when the conversation moment arrived,
she told him she was almost giving up
on her dream,
but she didn't tell him why
and what was her dream.
At the end of the event,
he took her hand, looked her in the eyes
and said,
"I believe in you.
I believe in your talent
Please don't give up on your dream.
I believe in you."
She was shocked, of course.
Who wouldn't be?
Because that man went from so far
to tell her so simple words
and at the same time,
so intense words for her.
Based on this support,
she decided to take a risk.
She decided to take an exam
called General Aircraft Knowledge,
and this exam you must take
if you want to be a flight attendant,
and she was approved on it.
That girl I told you the story about
was me two years ago.
I am a black-skinned girl
with curly braided hair
from the suburb of Rio in Brazil,
and I'm now believing again in my dream
to become a flight attendant.
I couldn't believe in the dream before
because my equation wasn't complete.
But I know I wouldn't be here
believing in this dream again
if it weren't for awesome people in
my life supporting me in different ways,
like my family,
my friends,
all of you, for sure.
And there is one thing
that I'd like to share with you.
I'd like to say that
in this current society,
I am part of the dreamers club.
I dream,
I make dreams,
and I love to help people
with their dreams, too
So there are two questions
that I'd like to make for you guys.
Are you a dreamer in this current society
and you help people's dreams, too?
Or are you just another face
in the crowd that can't dream anymore?
Henry Ford is often reported
to have said that:
“When everything seems to be against you,
remember that the plane takes off
against the Wind, not with it.”
I don’t know how the wind
is blowing for you today,
but I know you’ll solve the equation
that’s in your life
that I showed you before
and you will reach every dream
that are inside your heart.
Thank you.